les chérit les chiffres et je vous
demander d'accueillir tout de suite
madonna
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
merci qu'elle est allée battre à ma mère
ce match est il qu'elle hier elle a lui
ressemble sur la tête de ma mère on
dirait un mélange de madonna y de
maradona garde à bien
allez on va accueillir maintenant alors
oui il est où ce on va accueillir boy
george
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
mais
merci madame agathe invité benjamin
castaldi alpha qui se déguise en fait on
dirait sur un pocket déguisements
direction de raymond badiou et en plus
je s'éclatait talussot my hand ya du
sommet d'hier allait chérie je vous
demande d'accueillir maintenant il était
l'arrière neige tombe ils veulent
revenir les débuts de soirée
[Applaudissements]
guînes
de là
et en guadeloupe et
deux fois
je suis
tu tapes le tap tap
attention va cueillir maintenant et je
vous le dis en fait vous allez voir la
meuf en fait c'est pas changé c'est
pratiquement la même tenue qu'à
l'habitude de les voir qui fait chaque
masque en fait à s'habiller pareil c'est
la même personne
jacques basset partie
[Musique]
c'est la seule mauvaise quand même
esprit pour une grande chanteuse elle
était en loge avec sa robe rouge et noir
elle a joué premier degré c'est trop mal
à la clé on à capello des prêts en rouge
et noir
ça c'est pas au bout mais à ces
championnats sont pas mal
elle a un petit grain de voix merci aux
labos 6 à la beauce y aller maintenant
alors elle
je vous le dis vous connaissez plastic
bertrand ouais et ben là c'est marc
bertrand c'est plastic bertrand mais du
bled je regardais ça c'est pas ça plane
pour moi c'est choukrane pour moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
quand on regarde aller en métal un
gendarme était quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah le projet d'artistes qu'on va
accueillir jeu multi tout de suite
rien à voir donc je vais vous dire qui
c'est parce que rien à voir et à la
personne et il ya le gars qu'on va voir
ça là à la voir
george michael est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à l'école on ne sait quand jean-luc est
à l'as tu sais quand tu commences à
mettre la bouche comme ça là on sait que
dans l'attentât n'a valu que moi d'être
déchiré la vie vient de faire l'émission
avant c'est que d'atemi vont revenir
c'est jean shoot à danser frêle et ready
mercury est avec nous freddie mercury
est avec nous regardez le et vous allez
voir au tir en fait à trapéziste gare
rien à voir avec freddie mercury rôle
assez bas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tél
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le look de freddie mercury la
moustache
les brigades du tigre vous êtes dans la
fenêtre dire agathe du groupe duc au
cabaret aller igor a cool book of mercy
série on adore son titre confidences
pour confidences des confidences il nous
en a fait dans cette émission
alors regardez bien le cheveu du gard en
fait la perruque qui se sont trompés je
pense qu'ils ont pris des cheveux mais
une autre partie du corps regardez jean
schultheis et avec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est
[Musique]
vous avez vu cette forêt graphie de jean
schulteis noga normalement il est
derrière un piano le gars il est
tranquille et lui il est devenu commun
c'est à dire que en tant qu'artiste je
me suis permis de le personnaliser un
petit peu ah ouais bah oui et puis c'est
tout on n'en sait rien mais derrière son
piano
peut-être qu'il en est qu'est ce que
t'en sais en tout cas ici vous n'avez
pas de touche
allez merci
à céder la moitié l'impôt facilement
mathieu de la revoilà qui boîte un peu
on noie contre à plat mais non il nous
racontera pas pourquoi maintenant et on
ne savait pas m'a écouté je savais pas
et enfin elle est avec nous ce soir
merde c'est la plus sexy de la bande on
l'attendait avec plaisir regardez on a
déjà installé la piscine vous rappelez
elle est bien sabrina avec nos boys boys
boys
[Applaudissements]
bon bah qu'elles n'ont pas commis
mais souffler dedans pendant une heure
non soir mais c'est quoi c'est dû
comment ils ont fait tullow verger
trouver silicose un joujou on dirait des
vraies mais gardez les
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous lécher les bottes
ça va être la folie ce soir vous l'avez
remarqué